c'est le seul point de passage ouvert
entre la Russie et la Géorgie
la seule sortie de secours et derrière
ces montagnes côté russe se cachent des
kilomètres et des kilomètres de
véhicules ce n'est qu'un vol d'oiseau
qu'on peut en saisir l'ampleur un exode
comme on en a rarement vu ici
des milliers d'hommes surtout qui
attendent de passer une file si longue
qu'on leur a permis de traverser à vélo
ou à pied avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
nous avons envoyé une équipe et
rencontrer du côté georgien ils n'ont
pris qu'un sac à dos et son parti en
pleine
Micha réserviste dit qu'il a réussi à
s'enfuir Dorel en Russie juste avant
d'être convoqué par l'armée en payant un
pot de vin à la police locale
mais cette guerre est complètement
injustifiée et on refuse d'y aller
il y a des hommes partout même des
familles qui ont mis plus de 48 heures
pour arriver en Géorgie
romane vit en Géorgie depuis un mois
déjà et attend anxieusement que ces deux
fils viennent le rejoindre
[Musique]
mais ça y est ils sont sains et sauf
roman respire mieux
la 22 ans l'autre aura 18 dans 2
semaines là j'ai le profil pour être
conscrit puisqu'ils ne sont plus aux
études
mais pour chaque homme qui s'enfuit un
autre reste en Russie et se plie aux
ordres ces hommes de la région de Rostov
partent se battre en Ukraine dans
quelques minutes
on les bénit avant le départ
puis on les pleure les adieux sont
pénibles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est terrifiant prier pour qu'il
revienne en vie dit la femme de se
réserver difficile de savoir ce qu'il
pense lui mais devant la caméra il
assure que tout ira bien
ce couple a même décidé de se marier à
la dernière minute mais la jeune femme
est inconsolable
les mêmes scènes se répètent un peu
partout en Russie à homme ce qu'en
Sibérie
puis au d'aggestin où les femmes et les
hommes ont manifesté pour dénoncer la
mobilisation
[Applaudissements]
mais pour romane qui a sauvé ses fils il
est trop tard pour défier le régime de
Vladimir Poutine
un peu plus dit-il en Russie sans se
battre comme nous aurions dû le faire
contre le régime et nous voilà 20 ans
plus tard à se demander mon Dieu
qu'est-ce qui nous arrive
pour lui il vaut mieux s'enfuir comme le
font ses fils que de croupir en prison
ou encore pire de mourir pour rien au
front
c'est Tamara Alteresco Radio-Canada
Montréal